you don't mind if I listen to music
no absolutely not yeah you can listen
yeah the other problem with this is I
have to get like close to the mic it's
not like the mic earlier was between us
now I kinda have to like talk yeah it is
get situated this is how it should be
city
[Music]
and this this is physics my rational
physics like nope I got a file saved of
text file I just have like a whole bunch
of questions that I never get tasks or I
just saved for later that list is
getting longer and longer the longer way
so you never asked you get this across
holistic doesn't have like a whole bunch
of question just like I know but you
never get to ask or just save for later
that list of thoughts is the fun funny
thought okay three two one let's go one
two three here we are hello everyone
how's everyone today we're doing okay
over here and I had my son on the other
side as you know I guess and so we're
gonna continue a little bit from what we
did yesterday yesterday we started with
words and I was saying you know the
introduction was that words are
important and I know the subject is uh
boring to a lot of people out there they
say well yes I think I think we make the
subject interesting because we do early
because the first reaction that people
have is oh grandma grandma grandma this
really it's just like what the [ __ ] for
it I thought we're gonna talk physics
but you know once I think once you talk
a little bit into it's like it becomes
obvious if anything is kind of too
obvious where they go okay yeah we kind
of get that yeah you get that problem
where people kind of take it for granted
yeah yeah this this is the serious
problem yeah you know you go to the
forum where you discuss science with
someone physics science and from my
experience that's what I found out that
in the end it all comes a lot of it I'd
say 99% of it of the problems that you
have with that person if he disagrees
with you it's got to do with language
miscommunication miscommunication people
have different notions of what these
words mean it's I you know you might
disagree in the theory this guy might
say look I'm gonna do what particles the
other guy says I'm wrong or yeah but the
the problem is understanding the theory
to begin with and forget
you know forget about what you model it
with and the theory per se
it's the issue is language and and here
I have a case in point here's a that's
where you have to start you know you
gotta start defining and one of the
things you want to define is what
science is so I look up the word science
to see what it means today in this day
and age contemporary world right and
this is what we find we say we find
wikipedia says science from the latin
incendia
right meaning knowledge is a systematic
enterprise it's a corporation right
corporation systemic enterprise that
builds and organizes knowledge in the
form of testable explanations and
predictions about the universe they're
saying a lot of words the kind of planes
of the notion of what we have for
science but see we I got a problem here
right here and right here and then I
have a problem because you know they say
mathematics is the language of science
mathematics is the language of physics
and here you have two gentlemen that I
presented yesterday Seminyak and
Weinberg Weinberg being a Nobel Prize
right science doesn't explain science
describes and Weinberg says I don't
think mathematics can ever be regarded
as an explanation of anything and this
is not always well understood hold it so
so the definition of science according
to the wiki right is a systematic
enterprise that builds and organizes
knowledge in the form of testable
explanations and these peoples and they
say that mathematics is the language of
science and each people say well by the
way you know mathematics doesn't explain
so you see you see why we have to define
these terms yeah well we're running
around in circles and let people define
science as explanations they say math is
the language of science but then they
say oh by the way you know mathematics
does not explain so we got a problem but
I have a big problem with your
generalizations okay these people oh
these people then you you ascribe to a
vague amount of science mathematical
scientists no names no who or what or we
were talking about you just kind of say
they defined it this way and then the
mathematical physicists yeah yeah yeah a
problem because perhaps I mean very
often you're taking the definition of
one group of people or one person and
then saying someone else said oh we're
not a focus here for some reason yeah
you get close and it goes in focus then
I guess yeah if I move too fast maybe it
just goes out of whack
that's an hour and water and you're
sorry I'm so yeah the generalization of
these people or they is a problem
because if you say they define it a
certain way okay and then but then like
they define science one way and then
they they again misuse their own
definition by using these math or are
inconsistent then perhaps it's not the
same group of people in the book but it
is that's my point it is the same group
of people because you go into
mathematical physics you go into the
philosophy of science you go to the
standard what is it Stanford
encyclopedia of philosophy
and you find the same people so I call
they I guess I'm referring to the
establishment the mathematical
establishment the philosophical is that
there that's they never generalize the
people who run the world
I mean when you criticize someone you
can't criticize a group I think that's
that's that would be my take on it okay
so it's a rule because if you criticize
a group then maybe everyone in that
group doesn't use the same definitions
the same way so it's kind of hard to
group people to criticize a group we
take one person you can say exactly what
they said in once instance exactly
saying another so it's much more
straightforward to criticize a person
okay let's let's remove the people
completely let's just go with these
definitions you have a definition
in the wikipedia whoever put it in there
I don't care but this is the official
definition and you'll find it elsewhere
I've got other references by the way and
so they define science blah blah blah
blah blah explanations then you find
another statement somewhere else very
widely spread out there that you know
it's a big Buddhist and it says you know
the language of science is math and then
you find the third statement yeah it
comes from a couple guys but again
people have this these notions the
mathematicians at least hold these
notions and you should figure it out
anyways by yourself that mathematics can
only describe so we have a circle that
doesn't really meet you know there's a
one thing doesn't follow from the other
if science is about explaining and math
is the language of science and math does
not explain we have a problem we don't
have a full circle there you know are
many there's an open-ended circle
there's there are many people who
describe these words in that fashion in
the circular fashion or non circuit
because it doesn't get back to the
search it's like an open-ended circle
like you know if math if math is the
language of science science is about
explaining and math does not explain you
can only describe them we have a problem
we have to go back to the definitions
whoever has and start there again and
whoever categorizes them as such has a
problem that's why we have to raise the
board all over again and say look what
is science because we thought we knew I
mean at least in the last 400 years
since the days of Newton and even before
him with Galileo that's in the days of
Robert Boyle and Galileo and all these
people they started experimenting and so
from that they came up with a notion Oh
experiments then these guys came in the
mathematicians a little more
sophisticated they invented calculus you
had wizards like Huygens and
lightness in Germany and lutein in
England and you know a few in France
among them decart and you know and they
any they kind of said well you know
mathematics is important thing brought
they got that all the way from the
Greeks you know they're they always you
know they had that sign on the door of
Plato's Academy saying you know no one
who's not a geometry can enter here you
know you got a no math that are here and
so they kind of carry that all the way
to the days of Newton says yeah you need
math so math is not negotiable as far as
they were concerned and these guys
started doing experiments and showing
you know by the way Aristotle was wrong
you know he thought that the heavier
weight would fall to the ground faster
than the lighter way it turns out I did
you experiment and I showed the opposite
that he fought at the same time so they
said okay experimentation observation
they then they had math they put them
together say okay we're not gonna stray
from these two elements we need the
observation we need the experiments and
we need the math because but it turns
out but it turns out that just by having
the observation and the math you cannot
explain ya missing the third element
right I mean really the second element I
mean I don't think you need math at all
to be honest no you can't experiments
yeah but but because I mean obviously
there's many clues that we got of how
the universe works by experiments by
observe Kent yeah you say we didn't know
several things like the slit experiment
for example yeah if we never did this
Linux parent there are certain
properties of light that we wouldn't
have got inclusive but then the
observation itself so in other words
what I'm saying here is you need to know
where the experiment the observation
fits into the scientific method what I'm
saying is the experimentation the
observation per se does not fit in there
what I'm saying is you you you do your
experiment you can observe whatever you
want in your dark basement right well
when you come to the conference now you
gotta explain something to someone else
it's the explanation part that's
important we call that the theory but of
course you're gonna start with some
assumptions and since no one was in your
basement you know nobody was there to
verify what you did even if you show a
movie of it
you you know doing your experiment it
doesn't matter you know you just say let
us assume you know that this is what the
setup is you you you describe the setup
to your audience we put that under the
hypothesis under the assumptions but it
doesn't mean that you you go to the you
know to the to the conference and say
look I did the experiment and I verify
and I observe this in this no we don't
care what you observe just give us some
assumptions and tell us them what the
explanation is for you know for what you
observe we don't care what you observe
as far as as far as testimony in other
words yeah you don't say you don't say
this is what I saw okay I don't care
what you saw maybe you were drunk the
day you saw it or you were on drugs now
that's not the point is it isn't about
testimonies about repeatability is okay
I went to my base my pointing a laser at
a pen right you describe you can do this
at home that's the that's the part right
it's important with experiment which
like it's repeatable there's something
that anyone in the audience can do at
home you know if they have a certain
atom smasher if you can have well if you
have an atom smasher at home you can do
these terms that we did it sir you don't
need to have an atom smasher to show the
slit experiment all you need to do it
have a little needle like I showed in
the video and a little laser I will see
the what is it 10 cents but I think this
goes back to what we said like weeks ago
where they put a focus on the hypothesis
or not even like the pretty high pop
this is the the observation not maybe
act of gluing the years because the
observation kind of precedes the
assumptions in a way you do I do tests
so that you have better assumptions yeah
in a way but they put the kind of juice
of science the squeeze the importance of
science into the observations the
testable things what where as really
lower all I'm interested in is the end
product what is the theory what is the
how do you explain these things yeah and
let me tell you where all this comes
from and where the misunderstanding was
I explained it in my site and what
you'll notice is that you know in the
days of the Greece what they did
listy you know the geometers in against
geometry means measurement of the land
right it was they were measuring the
land that's where they had to develop
some of these measurements some of these
standards is landscaping yeah that's
that's what it's called geometry the
geometry you know but this but this is
the issue the issue is that when when a
guy like Euclid wrote his book geometry
they had a hypothesis and the hypothesis
was you know they did a lot of geometry
they did just plain geometry to
two-dimensional geometry so they went in
there and they talked about triangles
they talked about squares he talked
about circles and and so what they did
they started up by drawing a picture of
what they were going to explain in other
words they they want to show an angle of
something or they wanted to show the
length of something or that the length
of this equals the length of that or
whatever and the first thing the first
thing they did was draw they Illustrated
they Illustrated a triangle and said
that's what I'm gonna explain I'm gonna
talk about this you didn't observe this
this is an assumption that's why it's
called a hypothesis you look at the
picture and you say okay I understand
what the setup is I know what the
initial frame is of the movie that he's
gonna be explaining and that's what it
comes down to the hypothesis has to do
with the assumptions you make and you
have to make the assumptions in a little
picture what these people did after
Newton was they confused the high pot
already probably even before then they
confused the hypothesis with what
they're going to explain they say a
hypothesis is a theory that has not that
is in its infancy that it has not been
proven or is it's just speculation you
know you you haven't gone beyond the
speculation and that's not it hypotheses
have to do with the first frame in the
film or the first few frames in certain
cases what happened in one case and the
other one what is your setup what are
you going to explain I'm gonna explain
in the case of geometry what the angle
inside the triangle has to do in
relation with the other two trying
angles maybe something like that so the
first thing you do is you draw a
triangle you draw the angles you say
this is ABC and I'm gonna explain that a
is equal to B so so now the person looks
at the picture says okay I know what
he's going to explain and it turns out
that the explanation ended up with a
proof they say I can prove that this is
always the case there's always a 180
degrees inside a triangle for example
right and so now that you've got that
now you get the word proof introduced in
there and that's how the word proof has
survived to this day mathematicians talk
about proving but see now they carry
that out on words to theories and they
said oh we prove the theory of
relativity we prove the theory of
quantum mechanics no no you can prove a
triangle the the the mathematical
relations because that's known as a
proof in mathematics in geometry
don't don't extrapolate the word proof
and apply it to the theories to
explanations because now proof takes on
a different meaning now proof means that
you're gonna twist my arm and you're
gonna convince me that you're right
that's a major good point
that's a really good point then no we
never brought up or no one brings up the
difference between proving to a jury
yeah or proving a mathematical equation
mathematical proof versus essential
political proof college well explanation
of a phenomena is different than a
mathematical proof for example for
geometry like like mathematical proof
for example let's say you're seven one
one plus one is two it's more like
that's just how the rules of math and so
on anyone who follows math will and
eventually by logic end up with this
given these variations or the additions
right whatever you give them coordinates
if you put in a certain function to
always end up the same way in that sense
mathematical proof is proof the way we'd
like it to be in you know law or or
political proof but yeah look at a
lawyer keep that in mind you know where
do they use the word proof in the legal
world you have to prove to the to the
jury and then again we sentence people
who are innocent right
how many times have they let go a guy
who was on death row near zero by the
way this guy's been 15 years on death
row appealing his case and we found out
that his DNA doesn't match the murder
you know them go so how did they prove
it yeah so I gave proof means convincing
the jury it doesn't mean that you prove
it to mother nature it's not someone who
was bad at math who messed up it's it's
it's kind of more convincing more so you
know yeah and it's persuading to it
persuasion in that sense right
mathematical proof they need a different
word or because proof kind of got
convoluted yeah I'm that says that the
word kind of got corrupted and that's
where the word truth in fact come from
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah you're a
mathematical proof I mean it sucks the
eighth use two words now I'm in what we
really mean the mathematical proof is
not physical explanation it's a nice
concept I like that concept because it's
black and white
it's just mathematics time definitions
because you define what the number one
means what the number three we defined
what X and then just follows from the
logic right you can you can even go
beyond mathematic and call it logical
proof because you can apply it to any of
any any sort of logic you you place a
certain amount of rules
I mean definitions also go by this rule
yeah you give a word certain criteria
and now biological proof you just match
the word to the criteria to prove that
this what concept matches this word yeah
so you basically prove that gravity that
what you're talking about like if I were
to describe a concept just describe it
right yeah give you clues and you say
what concept I'm thinking of like like
charades then it's kind of like that
kind of proof yeah it's like the the
word that I'm describing matches the
criteria in that sense you've proven
that word matches that concept keep in
mind something you know is logic it in
in mathematics for logical proofs if
this than that right but they use the
word axiom what's an axiom again it's
like your your basic rules that your
original definitions it's your initial
set up and you know we don't use the
word action when we're
to something that happened a theory like
you know you talk about gravity you know
why does a pen fall to the floor you
don't introduce the word axiom in that
confuse oh let me show you the axioms
no no axiom is a word that belongs
almost strictly to mathematics so
they'll talk about axioms number one
number two number three what was our
union example those are the foundation
on example I mean well again it's like
you know when when you have certain very
close to definitions if you if you look
at Euclid's geometry
he's got definition he's got axioms
axiom is like a statement of truth but
it's like a statement like an assumption
a statement of an assumption the half
assumption have proof it's yeah yeah you
gotta look at the because he's got a
little mixture there but look at the
axioms in geometry just read a few of
them and he's got definitions like this
is what a point is you know that which
has no part so he defines that but
that's not an action man axiom is like
let's see I don't have an example of top
of my head but if you read a few clear
just the first page you'll find several
axiom in fact the first one is just
definition but the second page has some
axioms there and and you can see that
it's it's a statement of an assumption
have self-evident like half proof half
assumption and so you got a look at that
but my point here is that you don't use
the word assumption axiom you don't
bring it when you say well how does
gravity work you know you let go of the
pen and falls to the center of the earth
you know you don't bring the word axiom
there you might say let us assume you
might say hypothesize right or this is
my initial set up but you introduce the
word axiom and you might you might
introduce it maybe in logic but not when
you explain a phenomenon of physics and
you'll never find a word axiom there and
so again if axioms need to prove
mathematically
go prove I don't think you can translate
all that and you know extrapolate that
to physical explanation on physical
interpretation and say look I'm gonna be
talking about axioms and proof no it
doesn't fit in there now you're gonna
talk about let me explain the phenomenon
somewhere the way is a property is not
open to further yeah and again the way I
understand me move this over a little
bit here Shambo says Shamu don't
understand dumb mrs. state his name
there's no Shamu Oh cracks inside the
way I understand axiom have played to
philosophy the study of concepts is a
proposition that is not open to further
analysis yeah in other words it's like a
self-evident truth or and again it has
to do a lot with geometry of light
you say well the three I don't know if
this is an action but I'll put it as an
axiom the three angles internal and
angles of a triangle equal 180 degrees
and it's like a self-evident truth it's
like something's already been proven and
we just used as an axiom we introduced
it because we're gonna be proof or
explaining or proving something else so
you introduced it as a self-evident acts
axiom and again it's self-evident and
sometimes it's not I don't think they're
all self-evident for example I think one
axiom is a diameter bisects circle I
think that's that's I'm not even sure if
that's a definition or an axiom only as
an example okay here example is a human
that for example human action by Ludwig
von missus is their rational treatise of
over 900 pages built upon the axiom
humans act to remove their uneasiness
most urgently felt if that's K all nine
iron foot pages also if this if this
axiom is accepted it's kind of like a
it's gosh I should I like an assumption
but it's kinda like an assumption that
we've already assumed ya shampoo I I
don't know I don't know if you can do
in to explain behavior like if you're
gonna talk about psychology or
philosophy or some some other thing I
don't think you can talk about axioms in
that sense maxine is more like it's a
logical eveness than that yeah but that
makes an assumption people do X and your
name a person then you are doing it yeah
but look at the difference look at the
difference the difference is an
assumption means you're not conceding
the truth to the assumption you're just
asking the the jury to assume that it is
true for the purposes of understanding
the theory that's not exactly what an
axiom is an axiom like you said earlier
you know is a proposition that is not
open to questioning the further analysis
like this is the truth it's a fact so
you have to accept it's not like I'm
asking you to accept that you have to
accept that then that's the difference I
see between axiom and assumption or
hypothesis and I'm saying that hi the
word hypothesis you can talk about what
is it axioms in mathematic in a geometry
mathematical world but I don't think you
can talk about axioms and translate that
to the physical world there you have to
talk about assumptions because you're
going to beg on your knees that the jury
accept it not that you're gonna force it
down your throat that's what I like
assumptions and logic because with
assumptions you're essentially just
pulling out a whole bunch of rules or or
concepts and you're fitting the pieces
together and then by logic either the
pieces fit or they don't so you so you
throw out let's say three assumptions
and if those assumptions all fit
together
then that's a fine theory right but now
we have to kind of question the
assumptions if those are the assumptions
at all yeah but see I'm Shamu here's his
third statement there he says so it's a
foundation on which you can build to see
what follows rationally yeah that we
understand it's not a question it's not
a question of
if you agree with the axiom that's like
asking if you agree with the presenters
definition all I'm trying to say
Shambu is that I see a difference with
the word axiom from the word suppose su
position assumption or hypothesis
hypothesis might include both it's like
the father of both our axiom and the
Super's ation assumption but I think the
assumptions of physics are different
than the axioms of mathematics the
axioms of mathematics it's like you said
at first it's a proposition that cannot
be questioned it's it's it's a truth
it's a fact and you have to accept if
whereas the assumption is something you
ask the jury to accept you're saying
look please concede this so that you can
understand the theory that's where I see
the difference between axiom and
assumption and I'm saying you can't
really use the word acam maybe in
what's-his-name lui bum this is used or
you know axiom I'm not sure if that was
a valid use I don't see it used on a
regular basis you know the word axiom
almost belongs exclusively to math
you'll never hear the word axiom in the
context of physics in fact I've never
heard it in the context of quantum
mechanics or relativity when they
explain when they give a physical
interpretation if I had to use the word
axiom yeah I would kind of use it more
like an assumption that kind of has a
long history behind it yeah it's not a
simple assumption where I go okay let's
assume cats are black that's too simple
an axiom is more like like what he
brought up with with the example of
humans what humans act to remove their
uneasiness most urgently felt it's kind
of like a an assumption of a rule of
psychology now it's like a whole you're
right whole book on that so if we take
this huge book which is a huge
assumption basically no based on in the
zone that's an explanation based a
premise no no yeah yeah but but I mean
ramus and not the word certain acts you
but I just mean assume let's just think
that's better listen call it an
assumption yeah that theory or anything
is an assumption if this huge theory
right here this book over here
that's true yeah so you can't really
call it really an assumption I mean it
is an assumption obviously but it's it's
such a lengthy assumption I don't know
but he's not seen that he's seen that
not a thing okay I'm saying he's saying
that the book is based in other words
the explanation on what the guy expands
upon his entire dissertation is based on
on this thing he calls an axiom yeah an
axiom and I'm not sure you can use the
word axiom in in that country or eat it
up well you wouldn't shout Ramu says
well you wouldn't say Russian well
wouldn't you say rationality has an
axiom being something like nature
doesn't contradict itself or nothing
irrational can be factual you can
probably think of something clearer
yeah but the way I look at that is that
you know you say for example nature
doesn't contradict itself and someone
may not accept that axiom in other words
you might have a religious individual in
front of you unravel and he might not
agree with you and he'd say well I
disagree with that you know God
definition of super God can contradict
mother nature he doesn't contradict
himself but he can contradict mother
nature he might say that I don't know
you know you hear all kinds of people
out there so are you saying any of
something can be denied yeah but the
axiom is again unchallengeable that's
the notion I've always had of axiom that
an axiom is like a self-evident truth a
fact that cannot be challenged I guess
then but we're not gonna use the word
axiom so you don't really have to give
it a definition well no all I'm trying
to say is the word axiom belongs to
mathematical physics or geometry or any
of those but I don't know how you want
to use the word yeah are you nothing
well you are arguing in this sense that
I don't think you can introduce
something that's a self-evident fact in
the world of philosophy in the world of
psychology in the world of physics I
don't think you could take and talk
about self-evident truths because you
have opinions out there it's not like
1+1 you can say well that's an axiom you
know 1 plus 1 equals 2
you can't challenge that because it
follows from the definition so you just
introduce it as an action and that can
be a fact and I don't think anybody can
tell them something like that
on the other hand you know when you say
you know all all sons are read and you
know you just put that and say that's my
axiom and people might say well you know
I don't agree with that I don't think
all sons are ready you know so you know
you can't use that in physic the word
axiom I think it's it's in Congress we
used it that's my think one thing that
mathematics has going for itself is
logic that's something that's kind of
not talked enough about I mean people
think of scientific people as logical
but I think logic sometimes you scare me
with your logic because you're so like
robotic with it when you program or do
anything with robots you see how logical
logic gets you have to worry yeah you
have to use the computer to you know
kind of for know nothing but I like
logic we don't kind of don't talk about
logic you know because in a way I mean
you do talk about logic versus
rationality because they're kind of
cousins or brothers those two words are
really close to yeah rationality and
logic rationality just has like one or
two more criteria yeah logic is just if
this then that but we can use logic also
make point ons that's the definition of
supernatural yeah mathematics is a
formal science just like logic but it
looks like a lot I think logic is also
you can be used or I mean you use it
outside of math math math is essentially
run by logic but obviously but logic can
also be applied to qualitative things
that's the important thing because if
you go Teemu yeah because that's
essentially what you're doing with the
theory with the hypothesis you say okay
these are the rules with a hypothesis if
this then that if this and that and this
and that then you put the pieces
together I disagree look and I am and
this is just intuitively I have not
thought about this I it just came to my
mind the word logic belongs to
mathematics also and the word
rationality belongs to the world of
physics the world of behavior of the
world out there the real world
why because I'm saying that just like
the word logic and the word action
belongs to mathematics
I think did I say that the word action
belongs to mathematics the word logic
also belongs to mathematics because it
follows from the definitions of
mathematics and from the axioms of
mathematics whereas in the case of you
know philosophy with physics etc I think
you got to talk about rationality and
not about logic because if you want to
explain the my favorite one my favorite
example with magnetism right you want
explain Magnus's might as my go do one
you need you need to follow logic at
some point you have to follow a logical
set you use set out some presuppositions
some assumptions you put assumptions ok
let's assume we have little pieces of
metal let's assume they come together ok
now you have to put I mean that's the
one this those are more like observation
assumptions but we'll put those aside
the assumption to explain the phenomena
now you have to put in the invisible
right for example your throat theory
yeah we assume that they're connected by
ropes we assume that there's you know
threads swinging around these are all
assumptions from this hypothesis to fine
yeah the logical but I call that
rationality and rationality more applies
to the assumptions I think no no listen
listen this this is what I'm trying to
say you know we have to go back to see
how you define the words but yeah ok
right and we got to go a little deeper
in there but this this is my intuitive
feeling right now I'm saying that for
the for the theory to follow from the
assumptions in a physical theory I call
that rationality I don't call it logic
logic is a little more stringent it's
like yeah if your assumption or your I'm
sorry your axiom isn't 1 plus 1 equals 2
or you know the the diameter bisects the
circle whatever your your axiom is
unchallengeable then from there you
follow a logic because the logic is also
inescapable an in hand rationality just
says you know no I guess you know it's
got to follow from the assumptions but
the assumptions are not ground in stone
it's like
rationality was logic with like one
extra criteria we'd have to go back to
the definition to see what it was I was
almost there's one more thing our
defines an axiom the point at which you
find no ready way to continue
questioning the assumption easy in
nature doesn't contradict itself then
turn the other way and see you and see
what all follows from what you got but
that sounds also at some point like like
an assumption yes see I'm saying that we
this is my my gut feeling right now I
got a look at it a little deeper but the
way I look at it
axiom has to be defined for the purposes
of fit of mathematics including geometry
is specifically geometry and the word
logic follows from those unmovable
axioms unchallengeable axioms eligable
assumption yeah on the other hand in in
the world of physics in the world of
philosophy in the world of psychology
psychiatry whatever economics I don't
think you can talk about axioms you got
to talk about assumptions I'm gonna make
an assumption I'm gonna beg that you
believe in it that for the purposes that
you accepted that you granted for the
purposes of my explanation then the
explanation it must follow from that
assumption but then we don't call it
logic not in this world we'll call it
rationality why because I'm saying
rationality just says look it doesn't
mean that it's fixed in stone because
your assumption is not fixed in stone
it's just temporary to understand the
theory and over saying if it follows
from that will call it rational if it
doesn't follow from it it's called
irrational that's a little different
than the fixed world the objective
mathematical world of math where you
talk about axioms and logic that's where
I think there's a qualitative difference
between axioms and logic on one hand and
assumptions and rationality and the
other that's what I'm saying I think but
I got to look deeper in there this is a
new circuit they just came up
today but what I wanted to get to it
logic is the problem with mathematical
physicists and I'm also generalized at
this point but essentially what they're
doing is being illogical not irrational
the way you've criticized them they're
there they're already messing up at the
logic sense they'll put forward with
certain things and then use it in a
different way or right reality not logic
because logic logic would follow me on
the axiom yeah yeah but if they say like
uh-huh a plus B a C but then at some
point they they say a plus B is D or
something now they're messing up their
own logic I think that's how they do it
but see what did you mention you
mentioned a the context they let you
know you were in contact but the context
that you talked about just now is a
mathematical concept you cannot talk in
the world of physics in premises in
terms of premises I don't think you can
do that well yeah again a statement like
a like an axiom premise is an axiom is
confusing anyway yeah dispenses oh well
I gotta go and do some research on this
and find out exactly what the word
premise the word axiom what these words
actually mean yeah how they're used the
other night shyamalan basically breaks
it down the way no you broke it down at
one point where something rationality
has more ingredients than logic yeah not
all things that are logical or rational
but all things that are rational or
logical I think there's a quality I
remember you know I got a little hairy
but we have to go back to one of our
earlier videos that we already forgot
we're bad in our craft essentially you
should have this in the back more pocket
what's the nurse the difference between
rationality and logic rationality is
something else like like this the
initial scene or something like that
yeah and you just said it you just said
it look no no no no listen listen you
kind of said it if if a superstition
an assumption has to do with the initial
frames with us frames of the film you
know you're saying what was the scene
and you cannot really take a always a
pick
of the scene you have to kind of
describe it you got to say look I found
the body with a knife stuck to its back
there was a ladder or a staircase next
to the person there was a glass of
poison coming out of their hand
you know if you're gonna describe the
entire scene I'm not sure you can put
that as an axiom it's like that's the
assumption and you need a the first
frames of the film to focus the camera
on each segment of what you're
describing and so an assumption involves
several things there on the other hand
the the axiom the action is like you
know a photograph of again I can only
relate to geometry at this moment in
time say look this is the action for a
triangle certain things that you're
gonna spit out as truth as fact as
self-evident from the picture and that's
kind of different than the other one the
other one is let us assume and then
again when you go to the next step you
here you're going to go to an
explanation here you're gonna go to a
proof and in the case of the proof
you're gonna follow logic in the case of
an explanation you're going to follow
rationality yeah that's what breaks it
down for me as a language of
quantitative adverse mathematics doesn't
have the right ingredients for rational
analysis only logical analysis yeah they
essentially can do all the logic they
want yeah you're still not being
rational yes in that sense can we talk
about rational assumptions I mean we
talked a lot about rational theories
right yeah but can we talk about
rational assumptions like what your
assumption yeah yeah because it again do
you thought because you thought about
logic no no I I do I'm talking about
right irrational assumptions yeah the
irrational assumptions is for you to say
space-time is an object and then go on
from there yeah because you're saying
well space-time is not an object because
an object's that which has shape
according did the definition and you
know you cannot imagine the shape of
space-time because it's four-dimensional
so you know you get a combination in
your assumption or can you have a
logical assumption a logical assumption
well again I'm saying logic is separate
from assumption I put on the world
the physics logic I put on the world of
man but that's it's not exactly like
that yeah but you go because you at some
point need like we said all rational
things are logical but not all logical
things are rational yeah so you could be
doing
you could be logical but not be doing
physics but you can't be doing physics
without doing logic well let me disagree
there what I'm what I'm thinking you
heard me I heard you a disagreement in
here yeah I heard you and I disagree let
me tell you what I what I'm gonna
propose because I like black and white I
like you know I'm a very racist person
if the guy's black I'm gonna say
blagging I'm white and I like that
separation yeah yeah we have apartheid
in in science we need a part height in
time we need on off yes no black white
it can't be gray can't be well it's not
on it's not on and this is what I'm
getting it I'm saying let's use the
words in each let's separate the words
I'm saying that that axiom that the word
logic is not a subset of rationality
that's what I'm saying I'm saying these
are two separate words the other way
around
no I think rationality is a subset of
logic because rationality is logic with
a little bit extra with a little on top
I mean you define them as that's
something yeah but then anyway each
logic where it's like well but then I
didn't lose that's why I said it's a
subset because rationality has logic and
some gaps and what I'm saying is no
these two are separated by rivers are on
different banks of the river what I'm
saying is logic should be here
rationality should be here rationality
the word rational should be used for
behavior for explanations whereas the
whereas the word logic should be used
for proofs and and and what I'm talking
about proof is not that you're gonna
twist my arm
I'm talking about proof in a sense of
mathematical proof logical yeah so so
then over there the word prove I have no
problem with the use of the word proof
in math
headaches because the guy can show you
know that all these relations cannot be
avoided
you know mathematically that he can do
that there because they have some axiom
some definitions that applies only only
for mathematics and they can make sense
within that world of all these things
you can't translate that completely to
the world of physics to the world of
explanations of physical interpretations
you have to use the word assumption you
have to use the word rationality and you
have to use the word explanation not the
words axiom logic and proof that's what
I think these two words should be
separated but it's not so separate
because I mean the way we use those up
or even the way you live will separate
you define them as such words like logic
rationality is logic with a little extra
okay all I'm saying is I'm gonna I got
some homework to do obviously but I'm
gonna tell you where I'm going with this
I think I'm gonna separate those words
because I like black and white I'm a
racist apartheid type guy in science I
want things very clear and when they're
not clear when they're mixed when
there's these Venn diagrams that are you
know encroaching on each other I don't
like that gray area in the center
because then that creates a lot of
confusion oh yeah and it forces us into
circular reasoning no but it's not it
does in a way because B is still black
and white either something if there's a
Venn diagram yeah because something
could be rational but not logical done
it's just it's just it's something is
either logical other it isn't some
things either rational or it isn't and
I'm sitting up yeah what I'm saying
white I want to separate logic from
rationality axiom from assumption and
proof from explanation that's what I
want let's change the topic for ya yeah
and what is the relationship between
observations and assumptions observation
introduces an observer in other words a
witness and I'm saying in science we
operate like the Mafia you know we know
you know the witness never makes it to
the jury
okay but there's still there's out the
phone imprinted that earlier we talked
about about observe observations mean
kind of free assumptions preceding
assumptions where we kind of take our
assumptions from we don't just come up
with out assumptions out of our butt
okay okay but let me get a little deeper
than that observations what you did in
your basement
that's observation and the problem there
and the problem and I've got there is
that they use the word observation for
what they did not observe no but that's
that's an important point today
it's important because if you introduce
the word observation these guys are
gonna hijack it and they're gonna say oh
we observe now you did not observe you
did not observe like you did not observe
the atom you can tell me observed it you
did not observe a gluon to point a fine
point on that it's it's more than
they're talking about a derivative of an
observation the derivative of the word
of the patient yeah yeah because they
may observe something then they say okay
earlier we have an axiom that says if
this than that so they put it put the
the if and then get get me that and then
they say that that is the observation
right and it's really turn it into a
proof like it's exactly always we've
seen it but we never really see it we
really just derived it from our set of
axioms and that's a different sense yeah
but there's still the question what is
the relationship between observations
and assumptions because we're not just
coming me up coming up with random
assumptions right okay let me give you a
for instance you're the you're the
prosecutor you're gonna prosecute your
case and you put the witness understand
you know and then this woman begins yeah
I saw the robber coming through the
window that's an observation right right
but it's an observation based on her
personal you know maybe maybe she didn't
see the robber maybe she saw shadow oh
hold on hold on let's put a fine point
on that before we go further I wouldn't
call it an observation to be honest
maybe that's the wrong word because a
testimony from remembering yes that but
that's what you're an observation but
that's which it's converted into a am an
observation in a conference yes whether
that's true
sense you can never really relay an
observation because an observation is
kind of like the present right it only
exists in the present there's no future
observation there's no past imagery to
put your eyes in your in your eyes
that's a good point
observation in the strict sense of the
word if we're going to use a
scientifically consistently and we
really mean by observation I have other
words to explain you know recounting
what you saw that's different than an
observation or observation is only in
the present if it already happened it's
not observation anymore I'm observing
you right now that's an observation but
if I were to tell someone else what I
saw okay but who did they can put Edie
in there I can say now observe now you
know you kind of using common language
it's much easier to say I would like to
recount what I observe or what my memory
what I wear I remember that that's more
accurate yeah and you know that's if you
read the papers written by Faraday you
know he did a lot of experiments he
experimented for many years after Davy
Humphrey Humphrey Davy he died left the
job to Faraday and fairly began
experimenting with magnets electricity a
whole bunch of stuff there galvanometers
and you know if you read his is
expositions his papers the ones he wrote
they're really addresses to the Royal
Society and you know he doesn't say I
observe but he does say I observe but
he's more he's more objective he says I
did this experiment where I sent
electricity from here to there
he doesn't say I observed he says this
is the experiment I carried out and as
long as you're objective no problem but
that I think that's valid but if you say
I observe that having doctor with you
see but in a way it's just you're
testing for the same thing because
employed aces you're you're recounting
your you're pulling out from your memory
what you saw well new but so so so using
a word of observation is tricky this is
just remembering what do I remember what
did you see a man right I saw the guy
jump in through the window yeah forget
what you saw I remember seeing
the guy jumped into the way but this is
where I see the problem it's so easy for
people to say to take that testimony as
not as an assumption but as an axiom as
a proven fact that Salinger let's go
down the line because I'm still
interested in and then they challenge
the character of the witness I'm still
interested in the relationship between
observations and assumptions we haven't
got to assumptions yet
the chain really goes you see something
see here touch you you sense something
this is called sense to take yeah so you
said something in the present then now
it's the past real quick you go to the
quick you go to the garbage every aisle
we made the conference this is to speak
to the chain how it works so you you
let's just take see to make it simple so
you see something okay then you commit
it to memory okay and then now anytime
you recount what you saw now you are
pulling it from your memory yeah and
then but then the assumption comes right
now let's take a pen pointing to the
floor if you drop a pen right yeah the
first thing that happens you let go of
it and you see it go down so now in your
memory you go okay or you do it a
million times repeatability honesty you
do it harder time so now you've
committed a hundred pen drops a hundred
100 observations to memory so now in
your memory you go okay now from this
kind of we call reference experiences
from these reference experiences I'm
gonna create an assumption okay is that
how the chain works yeah I think I'm
trying to get a fine point on on the
relationship between observation memory
bank whatever you call it and then
assumption okay
okay because you're you're focusing on
the process to create an assumption from
an observation yeah I'm saying something
else I'm focusing in a different way I'm
saying you know we don't care what you
did in there baseball you observed in
your basement but when you come to the
conference and us you have to say let me
assume such an let us assume that this
is the setup in other words you got to
tell the de jure or you know the
listeners there
but I want to know where did you get the
acai acai that's a manly what if you
what are you gather matter no it doesn't
it wasn't it doesn't matter but but it's
just nice to know that's why man but let
me let me and let me give you another
scenario why it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter I know boy no this room
see even where you got it and this is
what I'm saying
I had a dream the other what is it
Martin Luther had a dream right so he
had a dream I don't think he literally
had it I have a dream okay so I had it I
had a dream I woke up and in my dream
you know I had this thought experiment I
didn't do any experiment I didn't
observe anything I didn't see I had a
dream I saw it in my mind so now I go to
the conference say look let us assume we
have this set up and they say well where
did you observe this where did you see
it well I saw it in here I never carried
out any experiment I never saw the black
hole all right I'm gonna make an
assumption that there is a black hole
because I saw it in my brain that's the
way I can explain it to myself with this
black hole that's the way it works I
think that's a different type of but
that's what hold on hold on yeah because
that's that's one that I wanted to get
to later because now you're talking
about derivative observations kind of
what they talked about with with the
when the mathematician used the word
observe when they're sometimes we're
talking about observations but usually
they're talking about derivatives
what do you mean derivatives like like
well if this then that
like they see for example the the Large
Hadron Collider they smash these two
atoms together and then they see on the
screen which is really just the
derivative they see all these dots or
particles or liens then they go ah these
lines are XYZ but that's really just a
derivative they're they're assuming that
that these things that what they see is
what they calculated earlier so so
they're not actually seeing the actual
particles they're just kind of like like
free that was my blonde on the piece of
paper I'm just it's just a derivative of
I'm kind of putting the invisible there
I'm not I didn't see the air I just see
its effect
so it's kind of like a derivative
observation okay but let me give you
another one area let me give you another
scenario shows again that it's more
complex and again I go to the black hole
not only you don't see you don't have to
see you don't have to observe anything
you just say look what happens you just
run this in your mind you say what
happens if all this matter called mass
because they don't even talk about
matter what happens if all this mass
gets crunched into a dot well let's call
it a black hole okay so now the guy
comes to the to the conference he didn't
observe anything he didn't he didn't
extrapolate it from from particles but I
would say he he just he just ran that
and entered II just ran and a an
equation in his mind he says if you have
concentration of mass you just talking
mass and we concentrated our point it's
got to have a lot of mass and no volume
so he calls that a black hole now he
uses it to move stars around or whatever
there's literally a derivative yeah it's
a derivative not from something he
observed like you said it
no knows that he didn't have to observe
this oh he did not observe like you just
hit in the example where the particles
he looks on the screens all the part of
saluted through his by a but he's he's
taking a derivative of something he
observed what is the black hole it's a
it's a star that collide never no it's a
derivative of mass if we take mass it's
we have mass mass has these properties
yeah so if we if we take this which is
also derivative we have alia riveters
but at some point they observe something
and then they just extrapolate
extrapolate okay but the point here is
that observation doesn't mean eyes it
just means that the guy can come up with
an assumption even without observing
that's all I'm saying yeah you don't
have much doubt on the other I know what
I'm we're going to you win that's why I
had this I think there's two different
what are you called ocean no no there's
like two different sources of
assumptions like where assumptions come
from most of them are really derivatives
at this point the the source of an
assumption when you assume today yes
yeah I mean obviously we're not doing
the pen drop we've seen the pen drop
we've got away apart for 50 years of pin
drop drop that fan a lot of times
gone up and so I can't explain what
that's that's the one I wanted to get to
the derivative because that's where most
of our assumptions come from night right
there's not really
absolutely it's not really you observe
something you commit it to memory and
then you make an assumption off of your
memory it's more like the axiom thing we
were talking about earlier where you
take an assumption
oh man that's complicated you you make
an assumption of a larger theory that
someone else already did which is this
by definition you rewrite the assumption
from his assumption yeah or from his
theory which is the consequence or the
domino effect of his assumption that
other person assumptions used as a
foundation for yours so let's say your
person a and he's person B yeah
person B makes an assumption that makes
a theory out of that and then you take
that guy's theory as an assumption right
and then you make a theory out of that
take another step we have for work yeah
but taking his theory as an assumption
that's what I'm talking about
you didn't observe anything right you
just took a derivative you're deriving
you took out his theory you took this
huge domino effect of thoughts of
assumptions theories of something Theory
assumption theory you think one of those
the one at the end of that you think
that is your assumption yeah so that's
the other type of assumption the source
of an assumption yeah and then in the in
the origins of assumption yeah and
that's the way it works once someone
says you know first you try to determine
what light is so the guy comes up and he
says okay i theorize that it's an
electromagnetic wave and these are the
characteristic this is the math behind
it etc right and now the other guy he
doesn't have to reinvent the wheel he
just says okay as an assumption he takes
the electromagnetic wave we said well
you know you don't we don't need to
cover that base again we'll just take it
as an assumption yeah and now he builds
a theory based on that he says okay now
I'm gonna explain the slit experiment
using that assumption and then the other
guy says okay now we've proven that or
and build something else oh yeah he
feels that a particle is at two places
at once based on the explanation of the
wave for the slit experiments again is
the guidance and um if I can see so far
it's only because I'm standing on the
shoulders down or something like that
newer said that yeah I mean she's a
physicist no he was a mathematician
heõs pretty close but that's the thing
we're already you're all just taking
everyone else's tears you kind of take
the theories or you kind of break other
people I mean what do you do you take
someone else's Theory personal you try
to figure out okay what what actually
happened here you break it down you try
to see can I take this as my assumption
you know you've got I think that's the
whole point of criticizing other
people's theories because if you get if
you get one that's right for example or
one day that you can work with and it's
like so you're you're looking for you're
looking for the holes and other people's
theories so that you can adopt it as
your own to explain something else yeah
if I want to explain light there's a lot
of theories out there about the
properties I forget how what light is
there just its properties that it's fast
okay now we have to research how did
they come up with this how do you
explain fast yeah no no I already
explained how did they come up with this
yeah because do I mean if I'm gonna take
that one if I'm gonna assume that light
is that fast now I have to feel you can
actually delve deep in this in this
theory to find out if I can use this as
my assumption so you're trying to
collect assumptions yeah or the the most
rational assumptions to you to build a
theory for your theory you're something
question that played you this what is
light yeah so you need to collect
assumptions from which to build this
thing you have to know know in
quotations that is fast you don't know
it has the slit experiment properties
you gotta knows oh they're orthogonal a
yeah but that's what I'm saying you're
not just pulling assumptions out of your
ass and that's why it's very important
to talk about the origin of assumptions
yeah and again a lot of things we take
for granted and we concede them as as
assumptions for as the foundations for
our own theater and that's why it's
important to talk about the origin of
songs
that way we're not just saying oh let's
just assume this and just like it's
willy-nilly like like like it doesn't
matter what assumptions we make it's
like yeah the assumptions I mean the
hypothesis is really everything of your
theory the theory is is just that you're
just putting the Lego blocks together
but we want to know what the let the
base blocks look like because that's
where that's where the whole thing
that's where the sins gonna sit so you
really have to have those can't have
quicksand there anyways I've got some
homework to do I'm gonna look at axioms
logic and proof versus assumptions
explanations and what's the other one I
missed one in rationality yeah I think
those have to be separate I got to do a
little homework there to find out what
these words exactly mean a little more
precisely and I'm gonna talk maybe a
little bit about that tomorrow one of
those a lot of these topics of logic and
rationality really get confused they do
but we have to clarify them because
again if you're gonna go into a forum or
you're gonna talk with your next-door
neighbor it's good that you have these
thing under your belt and be aware how
important words are and how it's
important to define these terms so you
know that that's where the pitfalls are
in the discussion where all the pitfalls
of the process of science know you know
if the press is also debate yeah yeah
because the other guys thinks you know
this is the way it is and you say well
let me tell you where the problem is the
problem is with your definition you want
to be productive you want to actually
figure out what we're talking you gotta
try this absolutely certain certain
rules are also gonna get or else we're
gonna get you know what most events or
arguments get to which is just a
circular thing yeah where they never
goes around so they're basically just
wasting time in an ego battle yeah and
they never actually figure out what are
we actually talking about
yeah again you said ego battle okay
we'll see you tomorrow same time same
station
hopefully we can continue the discussion
on this fascinating boring subject
what's tomorrow